you wrote after my dad died I had a
dream that left me with a statement less
impressed more involved yeah what do
those words mean to you
we got to be more than just happy to be
here
I'm big on gratitude but we've got to be
more than just thankful to be here or
dream it you can do it it's got to be
more than just dream it you can do it
that's impressed uh the dream is still
other van
um
if
I'm
here and so impressed
talking to you today
if I have a reverence
to an extent
I will not be able to be involved in
this conversation
I'll be too impressed I'll be
anticipating
oh what's that question he's gonna he's
gonna he's gonna ask oh I think I know
he's going this oh I think I know what
Andrew he might love to hear oh I I'm
not involved in conversation I'm too
impressed
so I'm removed
from the present
um
for me
what that literally meant to me
when that came to me in a dream and I
carved it in I remember carved it in a
tree it took a couple hours
I still want to still know where that
tree is
Santa Monica
it was uh um my father had moved on he'd
left this life all of a sudden it hit me
oh I don't have the safety net
my dad was above law and above religion
to me he had me he if ever really if I
really was in the if I really
needed him I trusted that he had my back
above law above anything
all of a sudden he's gone
I'm going
okay it hit me how much I've been
pretending to be the young man
I was trying to be and not actually put
my ass on the line and have enough
courage to take risk and actually own up
to the man that he was trying to that he
was teaching me to be
and I remember
the world got flat
that cloud that Mr Mayor that I saw
there was not way up there it was
it was fog in front of me now
and let's go into it it was
I kept
I'd say I probably gained even more
respect
for people and things
but I lost a certain amount of reverence
that was keeping me from feeling like I
deserved or I'd earned things or are
looking out for myself
or hold myself task
um
and I remember all the things that I and
I was just getting to go into Hollywood
the time so I was getting Fame was out
there
as one of those clouds
you know with being an actor and all of
a sudden celebrity and becoming famous
the reverence I had
I remember it just
it lowered down to eye level
and I was able to realize and go that's
not a that's not fairy dust and don't
give it so much credit to make it fairy
dust
like oh I not me no I could never no
look that in the eye with full respect
but less reverence at the same time
equidistant almost equal sublimation a
notice where I had been
condescending people and things and
patronizing and stuff and put things off
as like less than me and not worthy of
my time it
raised up to eye level and so they were
all flat in front of me and the world
was flat and I was able to
shoulders went back my heart rose up my
chin lifted up I looked the world looked
things in the eye I became probably less
sentimental
hopefully not to a level that I got
callous but I know it became less
sentimental
um
I became more courageous
because
you know when you have someone passed in
your life
or maybe it's similar to the situation
you're going on in your own life with
your Homeland you you sober up
on these mendacities that we deal with
every day and this this that we
that we that we we owe we give too much
credits or too much significance to and
you're like what am I doing
why am I I'm not even gonna let myself
emotionally get brought down or over
related by this situation because I'm
you this is it it doesn't really matter
in the big scheme
and so we we certain things that I found
reverence for and and hesitated from in
my life
I was now engaging with because I was
like oh it's live this live is live
let's look at the eye and and go forward
through it and deal with the
consequences
what do you make of death does that
scare you
I'm not looking forward to it but it
does not scare me
do you think about it
do you visualize it
I do
I do and
it's a beautiful visualization and a
beautiful dream when I go as part of the
food chain
it's not a good visualization when I go
as
part of a random act of violence in the
freaking drive-by or something because
the second
the act the the accident
it
breaks a story that I believe has
already been written
at least I don't have the capacity yet
to to put it into a a a a a story a
Divine story
of the lives that we we live
and so there's something ugly and gross
about it
and it happens all the time uh you know
to to people all the time I just feel
like when it's part of the food chain
when I go as part of the food Jam I'm
like Ah that's poetry part of the flow
of nature you return to Nature
yeah there's Grace and poetry in that
do you miss your father
think about him
when I think about him I do now when do
I think about him
thought about him yesterday
working through a script I'm working on
right now working on scene work
and I just had that quick little
reaction of
wanting to show him hey check this thing
that's right and then I
I don't get sad I go yeah he would have
loved he would have loved this
where's my mom
wants to be on the stage my dad would
have been on the front row
he's more fun to show stuff too yeah and
he would have and you know as as what he
would we would have he knew he was a
character he knew characters I've based
parts of all kinds of characters I've
played in them and the man that that I
am on people that he introduced me too
and who he was
um he would have loved the creative
process of working on a script or or
talking about hey movie that's why I
always say I love the movie Mud
because it's the one that I I visualized
and seen my dad come to me so many times
as a 12 year old and put his arm around
and go hey little buddy you seen this
movie called Mud God damn it it's a good
one let's go watch it
that now my dad was never got to see me
start a career in film but he was alive
five days
into the over he overlapped the first
five days of me working on my first film
days confused now that I think is
There's Something Beautiful about that
he didn't never ever come to the set we
didn't talk about it but he was alive
for me to start something that was more
than a
uh more than a fad that was something
that would become something that I love
to do and I do miss
not in you know and then I go out of
that do I I I we talked about him two
nights ago
with our with our daughter I was I was
rubbing my daughter's feet
and my mom who's living with this 91
comes in goes oh look at you just like
your pop
he's like what he goes oh because my dad
loved her
rub somebody's feet rub my mom's feet
rubbed all
of me and my brother's girlfriend's feet
when we would have a date yeah
they would come over early
because they knew they were going to get
a foot rub from Jim McConaughey and then
we'd come out me and Matilda Brothers on
this has been on for decades we come out
y'all ready to go buttoned up and
they're looking I'm like oh we ain't
going anywhere right now
and so we tell the story you know to my
to my daughter and I was like oh yeah my
dad's his hands and miss his hands his
hands could heal so you carry him in you
I hope so
I I I hope so and in
it's a uh
a challenge
for me and I suppose it's like this for
any
Sun
how much do we hang on to
and how much do we let go
involve
and update the OS and and and and and
and and try maybe better or different
you know
it's that there's certain things that I
know that I fully believe in it's like
when do we religious when do we Cast
Away Our Father you know when do we say
no I'm going after the dream I'm not
asking your permission
I I I
question that from time to time for
myself because I and it almost feels
blasphemic if that's a word sometimes I
feel like
you can't what are you doing you can't
check that and go like well no I'm not
sure if I want to really
and then I immediately kind of let
myself off because I believe where he is
he's going
well yeah you're free man yeah you're
not I'm not not
gonna hold back if you misread that or I
didn't teach you that as well as maybe I
wish I could have go you're free
you're not gonna lose trust that you're
not gonna lose it's in your DNA it's in
your lineage young man
still it's scary to not have a safety
net losing your father is scary in that
way you realize this world is just you
and some deep fundamental way it's just
you
yeah you're alone
yes
but I mean also not having that
it's such a gift of Deliverance though
as well
because it's a
I think it's an I mean
it's an awesome feeling to know
to know we're alone to know we don't
have that to know you don't have to take
two
or take three
that it's one take I mean the peripheral
vision
improves
you know the the the the the
link and understanding with our past
improves because I know for me I was not
ever considerate of my past at all
because that my dad had that
if I needed it he was my well for that
well he's gone you know I said he had
the literally had they have our back
well and then when they longer have our
back also I'm going like oh well maybe I
need to look back and start giving some
credit to how I got here
what I'm doing and where I'm heading it
gave me the first time courage to even
look over my shoulder
because again I didn't have to because I
don't have to look dad's got my back
oh dad gone
from this life he doesn't have your back
okay
so I mean
I don't know me because
it's inevitable I
I very quickly go to
all right in the in the pain the loss
and yes
even loan leanness which is different
from being alone
and loss
pretty immediately part and parcel with
the pain I felt it
in the pain you saw the gift the the red
light of losing your
losing your father pretty immediately
less impressed more involved I came like
a couple weeks
after moving on
is there a trick to that to see the gift
and the pain that's a good question is
is there a trick to it
not that I know of
I mean I don't
I have to I I
have to catch myself from
trying to intellectualize my way into
the reasoning
and not skip over real
feelings and discomfort
I mean I I did get that from my mom and
I have to watch it that that so
resilient that we just dust herself off
and get up and go
you want to sit in the feeling you want
to feel it you're willing to deeply feel
the pain I want to I want to deeply feel
it I want to look at the eye and deeply
feel it but I don't want to wallow in it
yeah
um now I was raised where you skipped
the deeply feel and let's go
and I've said it before but that will
lead to having
turn into a person who is a repeat
offender of the same crimes because you
you just get up and you don't
you don't have a winter in your life you
know what I mean you don't have you
there's no introspective time you don't
look over your shoulder in the into the
past and so you just get up and you're
like
all right I've I've stepped in the same
pile of whatever 100 times and I'm fine
I'll do it 101st doesn't hurt hell it's
good luck well hang on a minute maybe we
want to stop and go what can I learn
from that
but it it it it
I don't know of a trick
I think I think that I think that I
think our fifth there's any trick I
would say
it's just it how quickly can we admit
the inevitable
once you know it's inevitable how do we
get relative yeah not skip it not throw
it to the side not deny it which I'd
love to talk about that here sometimes
too about the value of denial sometimes
the value of denial yeah
um but how quickly do we do we
want something's inevitable go
okay any mind and heart time I'm
spending about going no I can't believe
that happened no or did that really
happen
anytime we spend it trying to deny that
what has already happened that seems to
me to be I'm not sure the value of that
time
so if any if there's any trick I would
say once you know something's inevitable
even though how painful it is or how
awesome it is
start getting relative with that and in
the relativity is seeing
there's a gift here and if I realize
that gift I'm
honoring now I'm on to building up
the beautiful passage of my father
leaving this life now I'm on the march
to go
yes let's let the Legacy let this become
omnipresent let him live through me let
me become more Hamlet